افتحها موازيه الامن القوميه الاسرائيلي
جمال بن كثير ومجموعه من المستوطنين باحات
المسجد الاقصى تحت حمايه الشرطه وقال بني
كثير اثناء الاقتحام ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لن تستسلما لتهديدات حماس
ويعد هذا اول عمليه اقتحام لبن كفير زعيم
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرفه مضطه اليه
حقيبه الامن القومي وقبل الساعات من اول
اجتماع الرسميا للحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده وقال ابن كثير ان الحكومه لا
تستسلم لتهديدات حركه حماس وان الحرم
القدسي هو المكان الاهم لشعب اسرائيل
وفي ردود الفعل حملت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بالامين لجنياهو
المسؤوليه عن اقتحام بني كثير للاقصى
ونتائجه على ساحه الصراع والمنطقه بجانبي
قال محافظ القدس ان اقتحام بني كفير
المسجد الاقصى تطور خطير ونتنياهو يتحمل
عواقبه وقد نطق باسم حماس حازم قاسم
النجمه اقتحام بكثير للمسجد الاقصى
استمرار لعدوان الاحتلال على المقدسات
الاسلاميه وحربه على هويه القدس العربيه
فقالت الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين الى
بني كثير يصبوا الزيت على النار ويتحدى
اراده الشعب الفلسطيني